tengo aquí un vídeo de uno de los
momentos más emocionantes en la historia
del deporte y para hacerlo aún más
emocionante los comentaristas hablan en
alemán y yo supongo que eso está bien
bajo las reglas de uso justo ya que voy
a usar esto para un problema de
matemáticas pero quiero que observen
este vídeo y después les voy a hacer una
pregunta al respecto
y eso es lo que son
preciosa
como pueden ver es emocionante en
cualquier idioma que se mire espero a mi
pregunta para ustedes es qué tan rápido
iba a usain bolt cuál era su velocidad
promedio o su rapidez promedio cuando él
corrió estos 100 metros de aquí y los
invito a que vean el vídeo tantas veces
como sea necesario para encontrarlo y
les voy a dar un tiempo para que piensan
al respecto
así que necesitamos encontrar qué tan
rápido iba a usain bolt en estos 100
metros para resolver este problema vamos
a contemplar lo que es la velocidad
promedio o rapidez promedio y es posible
que ustedes ya estén familiarizados con
esta noción de distancia
es igual a la rapidez o velocidad
aquí escribo rapidez por el tiempo y
normalmente escribimos la multiplicación
con este símbolo pero cuando llegamos a
álgebra este símbolo tradicional de
multiplicación puede volverse ambiguo
con la variable x así que en lugar de
usar la equis voy a usar el punto como
operador de multiplicación así que la
distancia es igual a la rapidez por el
tiempo y espero que esta noción sea
intuitiva para ustedes que si su rapidez
o velocidad fuera de 10 metros por
segundo por poner un ejemplo no es
necesariamente la velocidad o la rapidez
que tenía usain bolt pero si fuéramos
con una rapidez de 10 metros por segundo
y esto lo hiciéramos durante dos
segundos yo espero que esta sea una
noción intuitiva para ustedes de saber
que mi distancia fue de 20 metros ya que
son 10 metros por segundo por 2 segundos
y también funciona matemáticamente 10
por 2 es igual a 20 y tenemos segundos
en el denominador que se cancelan con
los segundos que están aquí en el
numerador aunque aquí abre 10 segundos
con ese y aquí lo escribí completo pero
se cancelan y nos quedamos con metros
está unidad de distancia quita el resto
del camino
pensemos en este problema qué
información es la que tenemos aquí
tenemos la distancia en el vídeo nos lo
dicen y les voy a dar 12 segundos para
que piensen en ello
bueno pues esta fue una carrera de 100
metros así que la distancia fue de 100
metros que otra cosa sabemos cuando
tratamos de determinar la rapidez es lo
que queremos saber qué otra cosa sabemos
además de la distancia
bueno pues conocemos el tiempo cuál es
el tiempo que le tomó a usain bolt
recorrer estos 100 metros y les voy a
dar otros segundos para que lo piensen
pues afortunadamente estaban llevando un
registro de todo el tiempo de la carrera
y también muestran que es un récord
mundial pero esto de aquí está en
segundos cuánto tiempo le llevó a usain
bolt terminar la carrera de los 100
metros pues fue de 9.58 segundos y aquí
pongo ese por segundos con esta
información de acá lo que ahora
trataremos de hacer es obtener la
rapidez en términos de metros por
segundo de esa expresión conocemos la
distancia y conocemos el tiempo bueno
vamos a sustituir estos valores dentro
de esta ecuación sabemos que la
distancia es de 100 metros y es igual a
la rapidez que aún no sabemos cuánto
vale así que aquí escribimos rapidez
usamos el mismo color rapidez
multiplicado por el tiempo y cuánto vale
el tiempo pues lo conocemos con 9.58
segundos y lo que nos interesa saber es
la rapidez como podemos encontrarla si
vemos el lado derecho de esta ecuación
en donde esta rapidez está multiplicada
por 9.58 segundos si yo pudiera dividir
esto entre 9.58 segundos pues tendría
solita mi rapidez y eso es lo que quiero
y bueno pues vamos a dividir este lado
derecho de la ecuación entre 9.58
segundos se cancelan estas unidades
haciendo el análisis dimensional que es
bueno no se preocupen en este momento
por ello y también se cancela el 9.58
pero no puedo hacer esto de un solo lado
de la ecuación si es que comenzamos el
enunciado que esto es igual a esta parte
de arriba si divido el lado derecho
entre 9.58 segundos para que se mantenga
la igualdad de esta ecuación tengo que
hacer lo mismo del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación es decir aquí también tengo que
dividir entre 9.58 segundos
si yo digo que algo es igual a otra cosa
y esta otra cosa la divido entre algo
más pues para mantener la igualdad tengo
que hacer lo mismo dividir este otro
lado entre la misma cantidad así que he
vivido entre 9.58 segundos y todo esto
lo hice justamente para que del lado
derecho pudiera cancelar todo esto de
arriba con esto de abajo y del lado
izquierdo me quedan 100 entre 9.58 y mis
unidades son metros por segundo que son
exactamente las unidades que me
interesan para esta rapidez saquemos la
calculadora para hacer esta división
dividimos 100 metros entre 9.58 segundos
y nos da 10.438 que vamos a usar aquí
dos dígitos significativos vamos a decir
que el resultado es de 10.4 y las
unidades son metros por segundo y esta
es mi rapidez
y ahora tengo otra pregunta esto está en
metros por segundo pero
desafortunadamente estas unidades de
rapidez no son demasiado familiares para
nosotros por ejemplo cuando vamos en un
auto el odómetro no tiene unidades de
metros por segundo
normalmente está en kilómetros por hora
o millas por hora así que la siguiente
tarea que vamos a hacer es expresar esta
rapidez y recordemos que esta es una
rapidez promedio o velocidad promedio
pero pensemos en esto en términos de
kilómetros por hora así pues vamos a
tratar de reescribir esto en kilómetros
por hora pues vamos a hacer esto paso a
paso
comenzamos con 10.4 aquí metros en azul
y segundos en magenta y ahora queremos
tener esto en kilómetros por hora pero
primero vamos a transformar esto en
kilómetros por segundo
vámonos pasito a pasito cómo podemos
transformar esto en kilómetros por
segundo
y dar unos momentos para que piensen
cómo podemos transformar esto a
kilómetros por segundo
la intuición aquí es que si tengo 10.4
metros por segundo cuántos kilómetros
equivalen estos 10 punto 4 metros bueno
un kilómetro es una unidad mucho más
grande que un metro es mil veces más
grande así que 10.4 metros va a ser una
cantidad mucho más pequeña en kilómetros
esto lo tengo que dividir entre 1000
otra forma de ver esto si quieren
enfocarse en el análisis dimensional o
en las unidades
yo quiero deshacerme de estos metros y
quiero que queden kilómetros así que
aquí queremos kilómetros y queremos
quitar los metros
si tenemos metros en el numerador y
tenemos metros en el denominador de este
lado ambos se van a cancelar y me va a
quedar kilómetros por segundo y ya
habíamos dicho que los metros es una
unidad mucho más pequeña que los
kilómetros sin embargo si vemos las
unidades lo que podemos hacer es bueno
cuántos metros habrá en un kilómetro un
kilómetro tiene mil metros
estoy aquí un kilómetro entre 1000
metros es uno entre uno no vamos a
cambiar el valor de esto ya que
esencialmente lo estamos multiplicando
por 1 pero cuando hacemos esto pues los
metros se cancelan nos quedan kilómetros
por segundo y con los números tenemos
10.4 entre 1000 10.4 dividido entre 1000
los va a dar bueno si dividimos entre 10
recorremos el punto decimal a la
izquierda en un lugar si dividimos entre
100 el punto decimal va otro lugar a la
izquierda y entre 1000 va a ser otro
lugar del punto decimal que se recorre a
la izquierda por lo que nos va a quedar
0.010 4 kilómetros por segundo
0.0 104 que es 10.4 entre 1000 y las
unidades que son kilómetros por segundo
y ahora tratemos de convertir esto en
kilómetros por hora
y también les daré tiempo para que
piensen al respecto
bueno hay 3600 segundos en una hora así
que cualquiera que sea la cantidad de
kilómetros que hago en un segundo
hacer 3600 veces eso en una hora y
también nos van a funcionar las unidades
si hago todo esto en un segundo voy a
multiplicar 3600 segundos que hay en una
hora y otra forma de verlo es que
queremos horas en el denominador y
queremos quitar los segundos si
multiplicamos por segundos por ahora que
tenemos 3600 segundos en una hora se van
a cancelar los segundos y nos quedará la
hora en el denominador cancelamos los
segundos nos quedamos con kilómetros por
hora y ahora vamos a hacer la operación
de los números multiplicar esto por 3600
saquemos la calculadora tenemos puntos 0
104 por 3600 nos da 37 puntos 44 que lo
redondeamos a 37.4 kilómetros por hora
y esta es su velocidad promedio en
kilómetros por hora lo último que quiero
hacer para aquellos de ustedes que se
encuentren en eeuu o que usan unidades
imperiales también llamadas unidades
inglesas que irónicamente no
necesariamente se usan en el reino unido
pero si se usan en eeuu así que hay que
convertir esto a millas por hora una
cosa que les voy a decir en caso de que
ustedes no la sepan es que 1.61 km es
igual a una milla les daré un poco de
tiempo para que convierta en esto en
millas por hora
pues como ven de aquí una milla es un
poquito más grande que un kilómetro así
que si recorremos 37.4 kilómetros en
cierta cantidad de tiempo recorreremos
una cantidad un poco más pequeña de
millas por esa misma cantidad de tiempo
así que vamos a dividir entre 1.61 si yo
tengo 37.4 kilómetros por hora vamos a
pasar a una unidad más grande así que lo
vamos a dividir tenemos una milla es
igual a 1.61 kilómetros y aquí también
las unidades nos van a funcionar ya que
queremos deshacernos de los kilómetros y
quedarnos con millas por hora así que
multiplicamos esto se va en los
kilómetros y dividimos entre 1.61
sacamos de nuevo la calculadora y
dividimos nuestro valor anterior entre
1.61 lo que nos da
23.25 y vamos a redondear lo a 23.3 así
que es 23.3 millas x
ahora lo que es obviamente bastante
rápido y esto lo hace el humano más
rápido pero quizás no es tan rápido como
ustedes podrían imaginarse en un auto
que va a 23.3 millas por hora o a 37.4
kilómetros por hora pues no es muy veloz
especialmente si lo comparamos con el
mundo animal en lo que esto realmente
pues no es sobresaliente en lo absoluto
de hecho es un poquito más lento que un
elefante que va corriendo un elefante
que se lanza la carga se ha medido que
va a 25 millas por hora